this is a production of Cornell
University
okay next up today we have Kirby Peters
Kirby is from Roxbury Connecticut he
worked with Matt Ryan Jeff Lee Bert and
Sandra women in soil and crop science
and his post graduation plans are to be
a greenhouse manager at Johnson backyard
garden in Austin Texas the title of
Kirby's seminar is soil to see soil seed
banks on for organic grain crop farms in
central New York okay so over on again
my name is Kirby Peters I'm an
agricultural science student graduating
a few weeks and the title of my project
I'll be presenting you today is the soil
seed banks on for organic grain crop
farms in central New York and my thesis
advisor again was Matt Matthew Ryan so
first I'm going to give you a quick
little outline of the project what we've
heard from several farmers that we know
is that red clover had been identified
as a volunteer crop on several its own
farms and so what we decided to do was a
sample the weed seed bank in order to
identify if this was truly there was
truly a red clover seed bank within
there within the soil so we measured is
the weed seed density the weed species
richness the red clover density and
lastly we looked at the we chief
community as a whole so first I think
we're talking what a soil DC bank is and
it's just a vial viable seed in the soil
that has a potential to germinate red
clover specifically is what we're
looking at and this is extremely common
in organic agriculture mainly because
organic agriculture connected synthetic
inputs so organic growers tend to rely
on biological biological inputs such as
our clover because it's a legume and it
can fix nitrogen to the soil with its
symbiotic relationship with bacteria so
as you can see here here's a picture of
a clover in case unit now it's nice
drawing and like I said a lot of a few
growers have mentions that they have
seen this crop as a volunteer crop and
what that means is basically the crop
has persisted past its time of the
rotation so clover can be frost seeded
or can also be seen in the fall go
through the winter and then
emerge in the spring and that's great
and all its unterminated in order to
take room from the for the crops that
could be a grain as as we like to say
wheat but the issue with a volunteer
crop is then it persists past that and
then it's still present in your crop so
many people see this as a negative as a
negative implication because you have
this described clover that's competing
with your crop for a lot of resources
whether it be nutrients sunlight or
water however this study conflicts it in
perspective this study looks at the
possible benefit of this volunteer works
over I mean there's many benefits to red
clover itself like I said it fixes
nitrogen however if we don't have to
seed red clover there's just this like
natural odor clover seed bank you can
save seed costs that's less less labor
you don't make a trip into the field to
broadcast you can also potentially
control the emergence of your red clover
this is beneficial because there's times
for example wet times of the year when
you cannot get into your field because
too wet however if you have this red
clover seed bank it'll come up anyways
so that's always a nice benefit so in
order to look at this red clover what we
did is we looked at it within the
context of the whole beet seed bank so
from there we decided just to make a
characterization the whole of the whole
beet seed bank itself so we did is we
did the study over two years this
happened this occurred in 2015 and so
them 16 we sampled four farms these
farmers are chosen from our Advisory
Board in our lab these are pretty
experienced organic growers these
organic growers that have that were some
of the first organic growers in the
state so when I say they're experienced
there they're very curious and so we're
thankful for them to volunteer for the
study what we did is we asked each
farmer to pick three fields they're
clean field I hike lower field and a
weedy field the idea what this is when
they chose for example had clover fields
it would be identifying a field with a
boatful receipt banks present it when
farmers were choosing their clean fields
generally or they're picking fields that
they observed
we'd abundance in at least above ground
but also they talked about how conducive
fields were for control someone farmer
mission to fry delegated soil as making
it more conducive for control for hog
clover fields farmers talked about
basically the presence it had in their
rotation but also all the farms were
harvesting red clover and for these
fields they said they noticed that a lot
of seed was dropping down to the soil
adding some red clover seed into the
soil seed bank and lastly low B D field
farmers chose this generally because
they had observed a high amount of
abundance in these fields and also they
talked about how some of these fields
were not so conducive for control so
some farmers talked about field thing
really wet and that kind of preventing
them in getting into the fields and
controlling weeds so here's just an
example this is the Potenza farm so you
can see he chose his weedy field here
his high clover field and lastly it's
clean field and then from there we did
our soil sampling and we split each
field into four quadrants and then we
sampled each quadrant soil sampling was
done an early spring before any wheats
had emerged as you can see here there
are no weeds present no weeds here and
soil sampling with some of the soil
probe this is what you see here and here
we would go 8 inches down the diameter
of the probe was about 5/8 of an inch
and we did so 30 soil cores per quadrant
and then from there what we would do
with the 30 soil cores if we would
combine them in a bucket as you see here
to make one composite sample per
quadrant so all in all we would have we
had four farms three fields and four
quadrants that was about 48 samples for
one year and after two years we did 90
96 samples so once we had that composite
sample what we did is we performed a
greenhouse termination by LSA this is
what you see here we would take one
kilogram of soil from each of those
composite samples and put them into one
of these traits so each sample was
representative and what in one of these
traits we go
Wow the weed seed in the soil to
germinate and then once we were able to
identify we would identify them count
them and then remove them and we would
identify them by distance species so
what we would do this is just an example
so once these had germinated we would
then identify them count them and remove
them that's considered one flush and we
did two flushes so after we identified
counted removed we then sir well-mixed
watered hopes to hopefully stimulate
some more germination of bloom species
and then again what the let them
germinate identified and remove them so
that's why we call two pushes in order
to analyze this data we use analysis of
variance or ANOVA and then to compare
the means we use the two keys Kraemer
method we analyze like it's in the
beginning we see density which is just
the total amount of weeds we feeling for
the observed weed species richness which
is the amount of species per farm or per
field varied clover density which is the
amount of October seedlings we
identified and then lastly the lead seek
community which is just looking at the
all the species and abundance you know
so first one were looking at here is the
blue tea density we observed you can see
our responsible is the soil we ttank
density per seedlings of ceilings per
meter squared it's important to
acknowledge that we compared with in
farms so we just compared the weedy hug
clover and cool and then each farm the
different letters indicate a significant
difference the NFP representing no
significant difference so it may take
ways from this is we saw a very large
range of we see densities so you can see
in the Martins high clover field in 2015
right here there was about three hundred
seedlings I done per meter squared
identified and then into them 16 in the
Austin era high clover field you can see
when it was a much larger it was a
hundred three thousand seedlings so this
is a very large range and then the next
thing we took away from this was that
almost all the really fields had higher
C densities than the clean fields
see here and here except for the one
example that we didn't see this was in
the Meijer farm in 2015 where there's no
significant difference between any of
the fields next we're looking at a low
weed species richness it's important to
acknowledge we're not looking in a area
variable now now we're looking in a mass
so we're looking at species richness per
species per Atilla gram this is a little
more variable however between years it
stays fairly constant so you can see
here in Martin's the weedy field had a
higher species richness than the clean
field in both years for my or seed
consistent no significant difference
between any of the fields
same thing with ocean air you can see
the BD field there was an observed
difference between the weedy field and
the high and the clean field and the
little bit of variance we saw was to mid
Potenza field and in the farm where he
saw the weedy field had a higher version
of spend the clean field however we need
to observe any difference in to them 16
so lastly we have the red clover density
this wasn't there wasn't as much
variation you can see here there was we
observe any difference in the Myers and
the Martins farm between fields same
thing with Potenza however we did notice
we saw a quite a bit of difference in
the Meyer farm we're in 2015 and 2016
the weedy fields had a higher red clover
density than the clean fields and same
with the high clover the only other
difference we saw was in the Oscar farm
in 2015 where the weedy field had a
higher regular density than both the
high clover and clean so now we're
looking at the lead will be called a
looot seed bank community data this is
just the species that make up the top
75% of the abundance from each farm so
as you can see here we have the total
amount abundance of the of the total
wheat seed bank community so what we
notice from this is that there was a lot
of overlap of species between farms you
can see paths rush here and paths across
here
you see sleeping species the main
species yeah there's a few wood sorrel
and other wood sorrel there there's some
commonality in a lot of farms
however there were specific species that
were common on all farms or the majority
of farms and some of these examples
where personal expedia you can see it
made of a high percentage of martin's in
the ocean air farm it was a lower
percentage on the Pens of farm however
it was still present there the next
example is giant Fox scale which we
found on a lot of farms on very and very
high percentages which you can see in
the Myers Potenza and Martin's farm and
lastly red clover wasn't necessarily a
common species amongst all farms however
just for the sake of this project and we
should point it out you can see in the
Martins farm wait about three percent of
the total abundance of weed seed was our
clover but what's really interesting in
Myers farm we had about 18 percent of
the total wheat seed bank density was
red clover which is a hot which is a
high amount of what we observed so now
we're looking at the 2016 not let's just
changed you can still see the same
similar common species giant rock so for
example still present in these three
farms a huge increase 43 percent of the
seed bank is now a giant foxtail but
yeah once again it's still present in
the Martin's and that's apartment
red clover you can see it now has
disappeared from the top 76% of the
Martins farm they decreased by half and
the Myers farm or from 18% to 9% and now
it is present in the protective arm so
there's a variation there so from some
conclusions forms project the first we
saw the majority the weedy fields had a
higher seed bank density than the clean
fields which so which suggests that
there's some support which behind the
farmers picking of each field what's
really interesting is we found the
presence of red clover in the seed bank
in many of the fields so we found the
red clover at less present in 22 of the
24 field
over the two years the density ranges
from zero to four thousand shillings per
meter squared and then lastly we saw
some we saw in certain farms that red
clover I made up a large percentage of
the wheat seed bank
so for example in the Myers farm they
made of eighteen percent and then lastly
our last conclusion is that there were
common species amongst the majority of
farms or all farms and those species
were giant foxtail pigweed species with
several species for same speed well
common lamb's-quarter and common ragweed
and this is this adds to some research
that we've already seen where these
species have been identified as promise
species in organic systems so the next
steps to take from this project would be
to determine management practices that
would support the or promote the
persistence of red clover seed banks
we've seen we know this is volunteering
we've also heard from any farmers to the
recs are utilizing this volunteer crop
so it's important that we start
investigating other other methods and
ways of managing red clover but also in
the context of this study it's important
to explore differences differences
between farms so for example in the
Myers farm we saw there very high
ultimate very high we saw high levels of
red clover compared to other farms and
it would just be good to explore the
differences in terms of management to
see why they have such higher levels and
how we could use those those manager
practices and other in other firms so
this this project without the possible
of course without the sustainable
cropping systems lab led by Matt Ryan my
great friend Jeff Siebert Sondra Wayman
Chris Pelzer and of course the poor
farmers that participate in this project
and then other people who just helped me
with presentation editing my thesis and
as well just other suggestions and
helpful guiding lessons spit thank you
practice scientific name yeah so I mean
I presented common names just because I
thought it'd be easier for the
presentation sake but no it is pretty
common to use scientific names for for
speeches or identifying yeah yes so we
saw we saw there was more annuals and
perennials for sure but there were some
perennials for example wood sorrel was
common we found that all farms but at
very low levels about like three percent
besides that I applaud my head I can't
think of any that were common amongst
all farms but the majority were Raynald
yeah
oh there's Jeff yeah so your first
question
remind me okay yes so for the for the
project for the for the paper at least
I'm writing I didn't present it here but
we have taken soil health data from each
farm so that sometimes we can we can
look at and analyze further so this is
what for people don't know soil health
two tests are just comprehensive tests
of biological factors chemical factors
and physical factors so soil structure
chemical pH one so you have that and
then your second question I'm sorry yeah
so it's an yet it's hard nitrogen it's
important have it balanced because
there's there's plenty of studies that
have shown that if you have exercises in
weeds are way more competitive at
digging up that nitrogen than crops so
it's really important but in general red
clover as a biological source of
nitrogen is fairly good at just staying
available for for crops just cuz that
it's not immediately available
necessarily if you incorporate as a
green manure well that's that's just the
gist I know there's probably a little
more complex than that
this really feels really factory how you
permanently help our factory on a new
core of the field yeah so I mean it
would be I think a longer term study
would be I would be great we only did
two years so we were only to see a
certain certain time period and there's
certain a few studies suggests that the
longer it takes a while for its
perceived bank space to adjust to
certain management practices so
unfortunately we don't necessarily see
that long-term effects of management it
was really have the dip to two years
however we have gone back and we've gone
about seven to four years back of
managerial practices from each farmer so
yeah we haven't even present it in this
but that is something we have been
looking at does that answer your
question
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu